we're gonna begin with this because
we've got lots of news to get to this
morning for you including violence
erupting overnight in the streets of
Puerto Rico after hundreds of thousands
turned out to call for the governor's
resignation David beg note will join us
from San Juan in just a moment but first
former Special Counsel Robert Muller
received a warning ahead of his highly
anticipated congressional testimony
tomorrow the Justice Department sent a
letter yesterday telling him to stick to
the boundaries of his report something
he'd already said he would do president
Trump meanwhile left the door open to
watching at least part of the hearing no
I'm not gonna be watching probably maybe
I'll see a little bit of it I'm not
gonna be what watching Muller because
you can't take all those bites out of
the Apple we had no collusion no
obstruction Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill forests Nancy highly-anticipated
appearance by Muller what can we expect
well we know he's going to be making an
opening statement Tony we know that the
Department of Justice has not reviewed
that statement but in the letter that
DOJ sent to Muller last night it sets
out strict strict instructions for him
telling him to stay within the
boundaries of his report and saying that
he cannot discuss the conduct of
uncharged third parties beyond what's
already written in his report the letter
goes on to call his testimony
unnecessary and cites executive
privilege as one of the reasons for
these boundaries saying that the
executive branch needs to be protected
tomorrow Muller is going to take about
five hours worth of questions from two
back-to-back committees tomorrow
Democrats are going to try to home in on
five incidents detailed in his report
that they believe would have led to
obstruction of justice charges for
anyone who was not a sitting president
those incidents had to do with the
president's attempts to fire Muller and
limit the scope of the investigation and
the president's public comments about
Paul Manafort and Michael Cohen those
comments Democrats believe amounted to
witness tampering Republicans are going
to ask Muller about what they see as the
bottom line here the fact that the
report did not conclude that there was
in between the Trump campaign and Russia
Nancy
Bob Muller has a reputation for being
very well-prepared for this kind of
thing but we also keep hearing about
preparation from lawmakers mock hearings
and the like how unusual is that it's
very unusual you know lawmakers are
notoriously bad at collaborating before
hearings like this they don't like
anyone telling them what to ask they're
all looking for their five minutes in
the Sun but in this case they're only
gonna get one bite at the Apple Robert
Muller is not going to be coming back
here in two weeks to answer questions
that they missed the last time so they
need to be strategic they need to cover
all the bases and they have to be
prepared for some very terse responses
as one aide put it to us Robert Muller
never gives a ten word answer when a
one-word answer will do and they know a
lot about his style because he was FBI
director for twelve years he has
testified here on Capitol Hill almost 90
times so he's got more experience in
settings like this than some of the
lawmakers who are gonna be grilling him
tomorrow a lot of people are gonna be
tuning in maybe even president trunk man
hey thank you very much and we will
bring you Robert Miller's full testimony
tomorrow morning in a CBS News special
report
CBS Evening News anchor and managing
editor Norah O'Donnell will lead our
coverage beginning at 8:15 a.m. Eastern
7:15 a.m. Central right here on CBS